y prometo al pueblo cumplir
fielmente
la constitución
y las leyes de colombia el centro de
bogotá se vistió de gala para recibir a
su nuevo equipo de gobierno gustavo
petro y francia- márquez la
vicepresidenta juramentaron el cargo en
una plaza de bolívar abarrotada donde se
congregaron miles de sus fieles y
personalidades políticas y diplomáticas
en su primer discurso como presidente
petro hizo alusión a su compromiso más
firme y decidido la paz la paz es el
sentido de mi vida es la esperanza de
colombia no podemos fallarle a la
sociedad colombiana los muertos se lo
merecen los vivos lo necesitan la vida
debe ser la base de la paz una vida
justa y segura una vida para vivir
sabroso para vivir feliz
para que la dicha y el progreso sea
nuestra identidad además el mandatario
mencionó asimismo su decálogo de
gobierno con un énfasis en la igualdad
con la creación de un ministerio
dedicado a ello que encabezará a
francia- márquez la lucha férrea contra
la corrupción o la defensa de la
biodiversidad y el medio ambiente sin
embargo la búsqueda de la llamada paz
total ocupó gran parte de su discurso y
se comprometió a seguir las
recomendaciones de la comisión de la
verdad para la implementación real y
efectiva de los acuerdos de paz tenemos
que terminar de una vez y para siempre
con seis décadas de violencia y
conflicto armado
yo diría con dos siglos de guerra
permanente la guerra eterna la guerra
perpetua de colombia
se puede
cumpliremos el acuerdo de paz por
delante cuatro años donde las
negociaciones y las políticas de
sometimiento con los grupos armados
ilegales la reforma tributaria o la
lucha contra la emergencia climática
serán asimismo grandes retos a llevar a
cabo por el primer presidente de
izquierda en la historia de colombia